and that before we talk about another
thing very quickly daniel radcliffe time
traveler we've had this on the show
before right yes I don't know if you're
familiar with this torrents diner active
time traveler this is the collection so
far like Dan raccoon to me under our
clothes this is my favorite one
that's a nice I look like a lot of old
women yes but very rarely men or boys
but two days ago but two days ago
someone found another one oh good this
is a this is a young lady in 1922 there
she is
I doubt these are all my past lives and
I just sort of a smiley dip to press
lady in all of them if you think you've
spotted dynaroo cliff in a former life
there do get a touch Graham Norton here
if you'd like to see even more stuff
like that then hit subscribe or don't
it's a free world but I know what I do
in that situation